Hey Andrew,
how's it going?
Pretty good.
How are you?
Can I ask you 67 questions?
Yeah,
sure.
Let's take a walk.
What is one thing you really like about London?
Um,
the music and culture
favorite part of the software stack.
Um,
the machine learning side.
You're getting your phd from Oxford.
Describe Oxford life in one word.
Uh,
intense.
What was the last project you worked on?
Uh,
an open source project called open mind.
Just looking to decentralize the control of AI.
If you could spend an evening with one famous person,
who would it be?
Barack Obama.
What do you do to relax?
Uh,
I play music.
Do you miss the US?
I do all the time.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
it,
I don't think you realize how important it is to develop relationships in a
place until,
uh,
until you leave it.
And then you know,
those people who are far away.
So yeah,
I miss them all the time.
What got you into AI?
Um,
I originally wanted to do it mostly for fun and also I thought that software
would be a really compelling way to be able to travel because I like being able
to work from my laptop and at the time I was really interested in playing music
and I was playing with a band and,
and a few other places and uh,
yeah,
I thought it would be a cool place to call it a travel,
uh,
and,
and work on my laptop on a tour bus.
Um,
and then discovered AI through a course at my university and just totally got
hooked.
Last thing you made with your hands,
a song,
last person you emailed.
Ooh,
I cold emailed a researcher in Tokyo who is doing research on the centralized AI
because the community is so small and I went to get to know everyone who's in
it.
What advice would you give yourself 10 years ago?
Okay.
An open mind to the different opportunities.
Don't commit to hard to just one and um,
yeah,
be ready for the,
the road that life might take you on.
What website do you waste time on Twitter?
You get an all expenses paid trip to one city,
where do you go?
Uh,
Toronto going next week to the decentralized Ai Conference.
Would you visit Mars?
Absolutely.
What is one thing you can't live without?
Uh,
my wife for sure.
Where do you envision machine learning will take us?
Um,
I think that's more a question on,
on how governance and sort of capitalism versus a redistribution of wealth plays
out.
Um,
because AI is mostly just a proxy for power and it's often controlled by the
people who control capital.
Um,
so all that has say it's really hard to tell,
but if history is any indicator,
um,
it's gonna be really hard to keep it from being aggravated into a few kind of
small powerful players.
Do you think religion has a place in science?
Ah,
I do,
which is a,
a bit of a contrarian view.
Um,
I view religion as a large body of work that is attempting to understand and
record things that are unexplainable.
Um,
whereas science is a corpus of work that attempts to explain things that are
explainable and are repeatable.
Um,
and I think both are ultimately trying to learn.
They're both trying to learn the same thing,
which is where are we and who are we and what really matters.
And I think that if you're trying to figure out what the world is about
yourself,
you should take both into account.
What text editor do you use?
I usually use sublime text,
but I'm using Adam more lately.
It's pretty cool.
What open source library do you really like?
Uh,
Pi Torch by torch.
What's one of your favorite movies?
Um,
Ooh,
Steve used to be my favorite.
Um,
but I really like interstellar.
I think it's awesome.
Yeah.
What's one of your hobbies outside of machine learning?
It's a plain cannon.
What was the first program you ever made?
Um,
I was in the second grade and my dad helps me make a simple calculator in c plus
plus and I've put it on a floppy disk and show it to my teacher at school.
What's a music genre you're really into?
Uh,
movie soundtracks because they make me feel like whatever I'm doing is epic.
Is there a programming language that you really don't like it?
Um,
is it bad to say Louis
programming,
language of choice for machine learning?
Uh,
Python for sure.
Favorite professor,
Dr. Hooper who first got me into AI and programming.
I'm going to go way.
What's one area of deep learning that interests you?
A lot?
Um,
I'm really interested in figuring out how
this is more in the deep cleaning industry than the deep learning algorithms
itself.
But I think that,
and I tweeted this the other day,
like algorithms are more commodities to the extent that everyone gives them away
for free.
So research into algorithms while it helps push forward what humanity can do,
I think it has less of an impact on what we will do.
And that's more controlled by sort of the data acquisition side of the industry.
So as far as something that I think is the most interesting and has the most
opportunity for social impact,
I don't think it's building the next great,
you know,
layer,
right.
I think it's probably a building,
the next great control structure for the natural resource that the deep learning
consumes,
which is data.
What is a misconception that people have about deep learning
that it's about the algorithms instead of about the data,
like,
like algorithms just extract information from large data sets.
Um,
and that's probably the greatest lesson that my supervisor has taught me so far.
Uh,
while at Oxford
name one person you really admire,
right?
I really admire the,
um,
this is really controversial but the former CEO of Firefox because I think that
uh,
people are generally rewarded now for not acting on their beliefs and for being
really passive.
Um,
and whereas there's definitely a case for that.
And,
and I'm a very open and accepting individual.
I also have tremendous respect for people who put it all on the line for,
for things that,
that they really believe in.
And I think that he did that.
What's the most beautiful thing in the world?
A smile.
What do you want to work on the most at deep mind?
Um,
I'm really interested in long term memory.
So,
so,
uh,
neural nets are really good at modeling short sequences and short range
dependencies and,
and saying,
you know,
given the beginning of a sentence,
finish it coherently,
but they have a really hard time saying,
ah,
I think I've read this before,
you know,
2000 pages ago.
And even finding exactly the same thing again.
So what I'd really like to work on there is his long term memory and episodic
memory,
especially as it pertains to reinforcement learning.
What are the people you've met had keep mind so far?
Um,
generous,
collaborative.
Some of them are hilarious.
Some of them are the kind of a group of odd balls and they know it and they
don't take themselves too seriously.
Uh,
I remember the one of the first guys I met,
he was wearing
a black kilts,
a pink bow tie,
and had like,
just this crazy haircut.
And I just remember thinking like,
wow,
that guy,
that guy's got to figure it out in that he's happy to be whoever is,
he's going to be wherever he's at and uh,
and work on cool stuff no matter what.
And then I think I grew up in a part of the country in the u s where were sort
of social signals like that would have discounted him from sort of academic
pursuits.
And I that's totally ridiculous.
And I was really,
really glad to see that
some people who,
the group that a lot of people would associate with being a member of the top
right.
Don't disqualify someone just because they have those kinds of social signals
or,
um,
or carry themselves in that way.
Right.
What is one thing that excites you?
Um,
hanging out with my wife.
Best advice you've ever received.
MMM.
Can you do something?
You should always know what your goal is
because otherwise you'll never know if he got there.
What's the bravest thing you've ever done?
That's a very friendly,
um,
I guess
get married.
Who's your favorite computer scientist?
That's David computer scientist.
Um,
there's a lot of great ones.
It's hard to discriminate.
Um,
I guess Alan Turing is a pretty easy answer on that one.
Do you think you'd need a phd to do machine learning?
No,
absolutely not.
Um,
and actually with the advent of online education,
there is a lot of,
it was a very strong case to be made that people can learn faster,
just the things they need to know by doing self study.
Um,
and I think that's a really good thing,
but it's also going to upset the establishment,
um,
and an America where education is highly overcapitalized and overhyped,
uh,
there's,
there's a big correction coming.
So no watch out
will the singularity happens.
Um,
I think that we will definitely get to a place where we can't tell the
difference between whether it's a human or it's not.
Um,
because humans are really good at,
we're really interested in mimicking ourselves.
So if you believe that that's singularity,
then absolutely.
Um,
now whether we'll actually be able to create something that's,
uh,
all powerful being that provides for us and answers all their questions and you
know,
is,
is kind of this all powerful entity.
I think that that's a little bit ridiculous,
mostly because they,
I,
that I've seen learns from data and I don't know that there's enough data out
there at the moment.
So
what is one area of machine learning that doesn't get enough love?
Uh,
same as before.
Data,
Dataset,
kind of power structures,
which is the natural resource that goes into Ai.
What's the most surprising result you've ever gotten from your research?
Uh,
bigger is better.
What is consciousness?
I don't know.
What was the last thing that frustrated you?
Um,
getting python to package dependencies.
They weren't part of the code.
What's your spirit animal?
My spirit animal
lion.
If you had a time machine,
where would you visit?
Either um,
the time,
either zero BC or zero d or a
since six years because it seems like everything was invented in the 60s.
Tell me a secret about yourself.
Just one
secret.
Um,
I tried to
don't have any secrets.
Where would you like to see yourself in the next five years?
Um,
I currently trying to figure out,
given the set of skills that I'm trying to acquire and then have the opportunity
to acquire,
uh,
what use of that actually matters and can actually have a real impact other than
making a company a bunch of money or automating a process.
Like,
it just seems like there's a lot of near misses in the AE industry right now for
applying these skills.
So,
um,
that's kind of the question of the hour that I don't have the answer to yet,
but I'm working on it.
Who's one person you would love to collaborate with?
Hmm.
Zuckerberg,
favorite Linux,
distro of boon to what's the point of life?
Um,
Ooh,
controversy,
controversial questions.
Um,
love God and love people.
Uh,
and yeah.
Have you built an app with machine learning that you've used in your day to day
life?
No,
actually got an,
a programming to do APP development,
but I've spent more time on the backend lately,
which is something I'd like to change.
What's something you've learned in the past month?
In the past month?
Um,
learned a lot of new things about homomorphic encryption.
that's kind of been a pursuit of study over the last six months to a year.
Um,
and I've also learned that there's an incredible amount of knowledge to be,
can you find a lot of new uses if you can find different fields in the
scientific study where people have done a ton of work but they haven't done a
lot of kind of cross work and like homework and encryption,
deep learning and even to some extent federal had learning.
Uh,
and blockchain are like these sort of these things where people have worked
really,
really hard independent kind of silos of research.
Uh,
but there's so much interesting low hanging fruit if you,
if you look at the cross between them.
Um,
and I think it's easy to look at that pursuit and just go,
oh,
buzzwords words or something.
But,
but these are legitimately interesting technologies and there's not,
I think we're only now starting to try to figure out,
okay,
how can we take kind of the power,
the power dynamics that we love about blockchain,
the,
the privacy dynamics that we love about encryption.
Um,
as well as,
as the intelligence of,
of deep learning and AI and,
and build the world we want to live in.
What is one really cool use case for machine learning that you haven't yet seen
done?
Predict
what outcomes are going to happen in my life as a result of the decisions that I
make.
Do you think will solve intelligence in your lifetime?
I hope so.
If you were in the world,
what's one law you'd enact
do unto others as you'd have them do unto you?
What's a problem that you would love to see solved?
Um,
close mindedness.
What were you like as a kid in grade school?
Uh,
I asked way too many questions and totally drove my parents and my teachers
crazy.
What resource do you use the most to learn about the latest breakthroughs?
Twitter.
Yeah,
for sure.
What's something that excites you about the future?
Uh,
I'm very hopeful that technology will give us the ability to decentralize
interest,
um,
and,
and sort of what we pursue for the first time ever.
Like I,
I,
it seems like we've had to make this trade off where we have to aggregate power
into these certain structures to sort of push us forward because when
everything's all apart,
does this logistical issue with innovating.
But,
um,
it might be possible with the Internet,
with blockchain in the,
like for us to actually innovate in a way where the interests and the return and
the,
the sort of goals that we're trying to achieve is actually built for the masses
and not just for the people who have capital.
If you were to start from scratch today,
what is a learning resource that you'd use to learn machine learning?
That's a good question.
Um,
but hopefully the things that I've written because that's why I wrote them.
Uh,
but other than that,
I think the Yaseen and degree is really strong.
Um,
and then I would look for 12 years,
12 year olds on youtube who,
who always have some of the best tutorial.
Cool.
All right,
Travis,
thanks for answering those questions.
Yeah,
man.
All right.
Have a good one.
You too.